cuál fue el aporte de corbacho no solo a
la unión soviética sino a lo que hoy es
rusia
bueno claramente sin gorbachov no abrir
lo que es la rusia contemporánea la
russa primero de boris yeltsin y luego
de vladimir putin
pero yo creo que gorbachov una de las
cosas que a veces estamos equivocando
cuando estamos hablando sobre el legado
gorbachov corbacho quería conservar a la
unión soviética él quería revivir la
idea que estaba detrás de la unión
soviética ley de comunista él quería era
informar realmente el país sin dejar que
desaparece lamentablemente resultó ser
una tarea que le salió de manos y ahora
tenemos lo que tenemos ahora cómo fue
que contribuyó al fin de la unión
soviética
yo creo que inicialmente michel
gorbachov lo que quería realmente es
tratar de ver y vivir en la idea
original de la unión soviética él
pensaba que a través de unas consultas
que el comienzo a hacer con la sociedad
civil soviética se puede realmente
volver a creer en estos ideales de la
revolución de 1917 resulte yo creo que
miguel gorbachov en ese entonces estaba
equivocado estas fuerzas ya no
estuvieron vivas y la unión soviética
estaba posiblemente destinado a caer
incluso más temprano y yo creo que
corbacho cuando entiende en los últimos
años o posiblemente ya durante el golpe
del estado del intento del golpe del
estado en 1991 y sobre todo en esta
última medio año de la unión sobre
diferencial de que no es posible salvar
la unión soviética y prácticamente el
dejar que las cosas van evolucionando
hacia el final de la unión soviética yo
creo que el papel de gorbachov es
precisamente esto
no e intento a salvar lo que no era
salvable y de esta manera evitó
posiblemente una guerra civil y veto
tener unos problemas más grandes que
realmente no había señor ruiz que ahora
cuál era la relación o la postura de
gorbachov con el gobierno del presidente
ruso vladimir putin
el corbacho fed y yo creo que él está en
el era un político a pesar de todo él
era político muy inteligente y él evitó
criticar abiertamente a vladimir putin
él estaba incluso en cierta manera
apoyando el intento de putin es llegar a
tener un rol decisivo de lucena área
internacional pero creo que lo que
estaba pasando ahora estaba fuera de
todo lo que apoyaba y valoraba corbacho